okay so Ted lasso is my fix for
everything having a bad day turn on some
Ted to cheer me up having a great day
turn on some Ted to celebrate and
because I can never get enough of
hearing Ted Talk hey now I took a look
at some fun behind the scenes action of
this awesome series he's here he's there
he's every bleep and where Roy Kent if
you're a fan of the show you probably
joined in on that chant within the first
few words
let's be honest as far as chance go it's
a banger but when you picture Good Old
Roy you'll probably see actor Brett
goldstein's face and he's probably
shouting the f word in every sentence
but what I recently found out is that
Brett wasn't even supposed to play Roy
Kent he was actually a writer on the
show before he landed the part and he
admitted that while they were writing
the first few apps he was envisioning
himself in the role even though he knew
none of the other writers were yet but
after they finished the scripts he
actually taped himself doing a few of
the scenes and then he sent it to the
producers dang best getting after it